has blessed me with your grace
has been forgotten
d
blessed with duration
thanks to the billboard awards for
recognizing initiatives such as
the art of dreams foundation where
we daily focus on transforming the world and
its realities through urban art
I hope this award serves  of
inspiration for a new generation
that can build causes better
partners we love you from the heart
thanks to the dreamers around the
world
today in which I supported my surprise I want
[Music]
this is a very special award and the
truth is that nothing like this has been written
whatever i say please
forgive me if i get confused i want to
thank the billboard awards for
this amazing award and i want to thank
this gentleman i have here to my
left daddy yankee
why
produce tubes and energy we weren't
here right now so thank you very
much  thank you thank you and most
importantly in spanish breaking
got thank you fans we take
gra  You're the same
[Applause]
[Music]